j'ai très content d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui est de surcroît avoir ce
privilège d'ouvrir les decks franchement
que d'appeler un colis pour faire
l'ouverture du bal dans le pays des
rêves da c'est la meilleure consécration
que je puisse avoir
alors ce que je vais vous proposer
aujourd'hui c'est de faire une va dire
une exploration de tout ce qui est
innovation et technologie est déjà assez
innovant en fait que d'organiser ce
telex asfi on va en voir
je rêve à vous parler de deux grandes on
va dire sujet aux préoccupations
la première s'intitule la chute des
coûts la baisse des coûts de la
technologie et si on les réunit
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à la technologie
et nous a transportés et nous a réunis
on a permis nous a permis de communiquer
ensemble certaines personnes qui se
trouvent à dix mille kilomètres ont pu
visiter asfi sans y mettre leurs pieds
ici alors cette baisse des coûts trouve
déjà une première réponse chez gordon
moore alors gordon moore pour ceux qui
ne le connaissent pas c'est le fondateur
d' intel vos ordinateurs sont tous
équipés par des microprocesseurs intel
et contenus en 1968 disait que la
performance des semi conducteurs est
amené à doubler tous les ans tout en
restant à coût constant
c'est extraordinaire cette cour où cette
loi de golden ball elle est toujours
d'actualité jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc
cinquante ans plus tard alors celui qui
a dit mieux qui a fait mieux
c'est réellement kurt weill et roman
kurt weill c'est un monteur ingénieurs
ingénieur en chef de google
il a été primé et décoré par trois
présidents des états unis il détient
quelque chose comme une vingtaine de
doctorats honorifiques et lui qu'est ce
qu'il a dit on est arrivé à une
conclusion extraordinaire c'est que
quand vous prenez quand vous prenez un
domaine donné la médecine par exemple
vous l'a doté d'une technologie et quand
ces technologies dispose d'un attribut
informations c'est à dire qu'elle peut
livrer qu'elle peut parler informations
et data bas ce domaine en entier
médecine par exemple est amené à doubler
de pertes
manse et de rester à coût constant et si
ce n'est de baisser en coup on va voir
un certain nombre d'exemples alors pour
illustrer cela quand vous achetez une
voiture je vous donner quelques exemples
vous achetez une voiture votre voiture
elle est dotée d'une capacité dans vos
dires ses 290 chevaux din ou
chevaux-vapeur ou 240 ou 300 chevaux din
en technologie on mesure sa grâce au
giga watts donc giga pour gigas et un
milliard et flops ces flottilles au
pricing points ce week-end c'est le
nombre d'opérations en virgule flottante
par seconde
ll voir que entre 1961 or aujourd'hui le
coût du gigaflops ce en 1961 cela
coûtait 8,3 milliards de dollars
aujourd'hui ça coûte 800
donc c'est pour vous dire la chute
vertigineuse en 55 ans du gigaflops
autre petit exemple vous avez tous entre
vos mains des joujoux des 'smartphones'
des iphone des samsung peu importe alors
ce que vous avez entre vos mains c'est
des équipements dotés de 120 gigaflops
et si vous tombez sur une machine à
remonter le temps à 1984 par exemple
rappelez vous c'était juste hier un les
jo de los angeles said aouita nawal
moutawakil mans deux premières médailles
d'or marocaine 1984 votre smartphone
aurait coûté 5 milliards de dollars je
dis bien milliards 5 milliards de
dollars c'est extraordinaire trois
autres petits exemples dans ce même
registre alors les imprimantes 3d
aujourd'hui au japon on construit des
immeubles grâce aux imprimantes 3d
on les a vus il ya 4 5 ans ben non les
imprimantes 3d didier date d'il ya 30
ans et déjà il ya 30 ans et le coûter
300 mille dollars
aujourd'hui pouvait en trouver dans le
commerce à moins de 200 dollars
les robots aussi
cela en fait que s'apparente plus à de
la science fiction non il ya une dizaine
d'années un robot coûter 500 mille
dollars
aujourd'hui pouvait on trouver à 22
milles dollars alors autre exemple
édifiant
c'est le séquencement du génome c'est le
séquencement de l'adn en médecine en
recherche en biologie c'est extrêmement
important parce que cela permet de
classifier l'espèce mais aussi de
trouver des protocoles un certain nombre
de pathologies dites héréditaire ou
génétiques
la première fois on a fait le
séquencement du génome en 1981 cela a
coûté 3 milliards de dollars aujourd'hui
cela coûte 1000 $ et aux états unis en
forme des adolescents de 13 14 ans à le
faire c'est extraordinaire alors ma
deuxième grande préoccupation c'est un
match que vous je vous propose de jouer
entre l'abondance et la rareté scarifié
cerveau de tenir le score alors
l'abandon ce pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de deux
messages que nous envoie les mass médias
sur un plan de qui est noir on va
communiquer sur les guerres sur l'écrit
sur trempe sur un certain nombre
d'informations en fait comme ça qu'ils
noircissent le tableau alors regardons
en termes de qualité de vie sur les 110
ans cent dix dernières années le commun
des mortels entre nous aujourd'hui vit
mieux que les rois les empereurs ou les
bourgeois d'il ya un millier d'années
alors la longévité a doublé
le coût de la nourriture a été divisée
par dix le revenu moyen par capita a
triplé le coût de l'électricité a été
divisé par 10 le coût de la
communication a été divisé par 10 le
coût de transport a été divisé par 100
c'est pour vous dire que nous vivons
dans un monde meilleur
toutefois notre système d'éducation et
de formation est en faillite et c'est là
où la raf t va pointer sans but de
l'égalisation
nos systèmes de formation et d'éducation
ont été projetés sur l'ouest et
l'organisation scientifique du travail
sur le terrorisme du début des années
1900 c'est pour ça que nous sommes en
faillite on a toujours formé le
financier tel qu'on l'a fait sur les 203
100 dernières années sont préoccupés du
développement dans le monde de la
finance
on a aussi formé le gestionnaire des
ressources humaines sur un quelque chose
qui n'a rien à voir avec la gestion des
humains
on a aussi formé des génies drôle y
tient et désigne électricien sur le
comment gérer l'eau et l'énergie sont
pour autant leur apprendre ce que mère
nature et mère terre disposés et
regorger de possibilités et de
ressources et c'est là où je tiens à
rendre hommage à deux grandes
personnalités
peter diamond et raymond kerviel encore
une fois lui qui ont lancé une
université aux états unis très
précisément à silicon valley cette
université qui n'est pas homologuée par
l'état américain mais qui forment leurs
étudiants sur les innovations qui vont
impacter le monde de demain leurs motos
leur devise
vous l'avez devant vous c'est impacter
positivement 10 milliards de personnes
sur les dix prochaines années un
milliard de personnes sur les dix
prochaines années
ce extraordinaire alors l'abondance dans
le monde de la photo aujourd'hui à un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont pris
des photos aujourd'hui ça coûte 0 la
bande ans dont la photo je crois eastman
kodak vous la connaissez tous va acheter
des pellicules kodak dans le temps et
l'a pris à sont dépourvus
aujourd'hui kodak est en train de
disparaître et les valoriser à 178
millions de dollars
alors keynes ta g est valorisée à 30 7
milliards de dollars snap chatte est
valorisé à 25 milliards de dollars
snap chatte a fait aujourd'hui les deux
plus jeunes milliardaires dont le monde
qui sont les deux fondateurs de snapshot
alors pour ceux ci je vais vous raconter
une petite anecdote qui arrivait à nos
copains il ya quatre cinq mois il était
en déplacement en amérique du sud afin
d'effacer son jet lag donc son décalage
horaire il va boire un café
mon premier starbucks qu'il croise donc
il va chez le barista commandes sont
qu'a fait le mari ça suppose la question
comment vous appelez-vous monsieur dans
classiquement le copain répond patins et
le pari face inscrits basse sur le
gobelet alors ils en rigolent notre
copain et prend en photo c'est l'image
jouer devant vous et le ballon sur les
réseaux sociaux ils n'envoient par
whatsapp communication virale et il nous
dit la prochaine fois appelé moi-même
auxelles au mieux et donc on en rigolait
quelques semaines plus tard je lis un
article sur le net qui développe en fait
c'est technique chez les baristas de
starbucks s'est voulue en fait ils ne
rigolent pas ces gens c'est voulu c'est
industrialisés s'est professionnalisé
que de déformer votre prénom
parce qu'ils savent vais le prendre en
photo et le balancer sur les réseaux
sociaux
et ça va augmenter leur notoriété et
leur promotion et donc message encore
subliminal à chaque fois qu'on est
quelque part on va aller chercher à
prendre un café chez starbucks deuxième
exemple sur la gestion de l'image et de
la photo alors on a réussi à faire venir
des x fi imaginez que demain j'ai en
annexe on a un starbucks a suivi alors
je vais prendre mon café je commande mon
café je le paye je suis servi je vais
m'attabler pour voir mon café
alors je goûte il a un mauvais goût un
goût infâme jeter quoi donc je prends en
photo je le balance sur les réseaux
sociaux je le poste sur la fanpage de
starbucks et jeudi café infâme qu'est ce
qui arrive
juste dans l'instant même vous avez ce
qu'on appelle des algorithmes des
programmes démons qui tournent 24 heures
sur 24 qui vont scruter
l'image qui vont en déduire qu'il ya un
logo starbucks bien évidemment sur la
photo il ya aussi les coordonnées gps et
donc on saura que cette photo ap t a été
prise chez starbucks est vide
les algorithmes aussi qui font l'analyse
sémantique sauront que café infâme est
un message négatif alors ces trois
informations vont monter au centre de
données de starbucks et vont descendre
automatiquement en instantané chez les
baristas et le gérant de starbucks asfi
qui renvoie son client encore attablés
par tout ceci se passe en fraction de
seconde le client encore attablés et
donc le gérant pourra demander ses
excuses remplacer le café ou peut-être
anticipé à ce que cela n'arrive avec
d'autres clients
ce que je suis en train de vous
développer c'est ce qu'on appelle le big
data et donc ça n'aurait jamais pu
arriver avec les photos d'antan sur
papier ou sur carton et donc voilà en
fait ce que l'abondance dans un certain
nombre de d'industrie peut apporter
alors cette abondance elle atteindra son
paroxysme dans quelques années parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes deux
milliards de personnes à accéder à
internet à l'horizon de 2020
nous serons 5 milliards grâce à deux
grands projets celui de google dont
celui de google
le projet et s'intitule bouclant et
celui de facebook le projet s'intitule
facebook jaws ces deux géants
aujourd'hui ils sont en train de
travailler pour connecter le monde
entier à internet à plus tard plein
dernière l'onu a déclaré
l'accès à internet comme droit
fondamental
alors mon coup de coeur va à ses device
cela qu'on appelle
qualcomm trail corde peter diamond est
ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure à la
tête d'une fondation qui s'appelle x
prize a lancé une compétition dotée d'un
prix de dix millions de dollars à
l'équipe de chercheurs d'informaticiens
et de médecins qui vont arriver demain à
diagnostiquer un certain nombre de
pathologies
grâce à cet équipement qui a la taille
d'un smartphone alors demain on pourra
diagnostiquer quelque chose comme
l'année missive relation artérielle
tequilla rytme maladies pulmonaires
bronchites chroniques diabète
leucocytose hépatites un rap née du
sommet l'avc tuberculose infection
urinaire donc tout ceci sera demain
diagnostiqué grâce à un smartphone c'est
incroyable il pourra aussi faire un
certain nombre de dépistages dépistage
du cholestérol du sida de l' hyper et de
l'ipo thyroïde alors si vous êtes un
hypocondriaque acheter deux ou trois de
perpignan est un qui tombe en panne on
alors pour comparer des indicateurs
c'était une vanne fallait rigolé
scherwey
non sérieusement nan sérieusement penser
à tous ces endroits du globe où le
nombre de médecins est insuffisant
rapporté à la population
c'est extraordinaire alors dans ce même
ordre d'idées abondance dont le solaire
vous savez que tous consomme tout ce
qu'on consomme en une année de toutes
sortes d'énergies confondues le brun le
gaz naturel le thermique le nucléaire le
solaire lui même tous consomme en une
année ne fait que 80% de ce que absente
la terre en une heure en termes
d'énergie solaire donc l'avenir est
encore radieux alors là je tiens à
saluer en fait notre pays le maroc à
tête à la sa tête sa majesté que dieu le
glorifie dans cette dans ce grand virage
d'aller vers le solaire savait que les
stations nour d'aujourd'hui sur what
that devons développer quelque chose
comme 500 82 mégawatts heure nous venons
de
dépassé sur la star en californie est
doté de 579 mégawattheure nous sommes
tout juste derrière cam outils en est un
qui fend 648 mégawattheure mais à terme
les projets nord sont vont développer
quelque chose comme 2000 mégawatts heure
alors à l'instar du ying et du yang
je ne peux pas parler du solaire sans
parler de long et sachez que des gens 14
février 1990 les ingénieurs de la nasa
on demandait à ils ont envoyé des
instructions à la sonde voyager roanne
dans l'espace qui se trouvait à 6
milliards de kilomètres de prendre une
photo de la terre cette belle photo a
été baptisé des pays de lourdes date
ça veut dire que dans l'espace la terre
est vu comme étant une goutte d'eau
extraordinaire en fait le potentiel dont
regorge notre planète en termes de
ressources d'eau alors un autre
inventaire raki inventeur à qui je veux
saluer l'invention aujourd'hui c'est
dean kamen savez qu'aujourd'hui un avons
un monsieur américain américain qui a
inventé l'équivalent d'un mini bar qui
permet de produire de l'eau potable à
partir de n'importe quelle source d'eau
alors la technologie utilisée on appelle
la distillation par compression de la
vapeur et il peut marcher cet équipement
peut marcher
par exemple grâce à du fumier de vache
comme comme combustible alors dernier
exemple on va rigoler sachez que demain
il nous sera impossible de mentir
vous êtes avoir une application sur
votre smartphone qui développe une
technologie qui regroupe ce qu'on
appelle la reconnaissance faciale des
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle
et l'analyse la reconnaissance vocale
c'est extraordinaire ce que cela va
apporter dont la relation
interpersonnelle des hommes entre eux
alors bannie os x men nos efforts vont
s'empresser de lâcheté pour les
commerciaux il faut se tourner 7
dans la bouche avant de votre client je
crois que pour les politiciens faut
changer de job
alors l'année dernière j'avais donné une
présentation à l'unesco à paris qui
s'intitule quand l'afrique se réveillera
le monde tremblera
c'est là où je veux rendre hommage à ce
grand grand continent parce que 70% de
la population en afrique
à moins de 25 ans et c'est pour cela que
mon message est d'investir dans
l'innovation dans la technologie pour
canaliser en fait l'effort de cette
jeunesse
je vous remercie